Imagine a future where your toaster
anticipates what kind of toast you want
during the day. It scans the Internet
for new and exciting types of toast.
Maybe it asks you about your day and
wants to chat about new achievements in
toast technology.
At what level would it become a person?
At which point will you ask yourself if
your toaster has feelings, if it did,
would unplug it,
be murdered and would you still own it?
Will we someday be forced
to give our machines rights?
Ai is already all around you.
It makes sure discounters are
stocked with enough snacks.
It serves you up just the right Internet
ad and you may have even read a new
story written entirely by a machine.
Right now we look at chat bots like Siri
and laugh at their primitive simulation
emotions,
but it's likely that we will have to deal
with beings that make it hard to draw
the line between real
and simulated humanity.
Are there any machines in
existence that deserve rights?
Most likely not yet, but if they
come we are not prepared for it.
Most of the philosophy of rights is
ill equipped to deal with the case of
artificial intelligence.
Most claims for right with a human or
animal are centered around the question of
consciousness.
Unfortunately,
nobody knows what consciousness
is something that it's immaterial.
Others say it's a state of
matter like gas or liquid.
Regardless of the precise definition,
we have an intuitive knowledge of
consciousness because we experience it.
We are aware of ourselves and our
surroundings and know what unconsciousness
feels like.
Some neuroscientists believe that any
sufficiently advanced system can generate
consciousness, so if your toast
is hardware was powerful enough,
it may become self aware. If it
does what it deserve. Rights,
well,
not so fast would what we define as
rights make sense to as consciousness
entitles beings to have rights because
it gives a being the ability to suffer.
It means the ability to not only
feel pain but to be aware of it.
Robots don't suffer and they probably
won't unless we programmed them to without
pain or pleasure. There's no
preference and rights are meaningless.
Our human rights are deeply
tied to our own programming.
For example, we dislike pain because
our brains evolved to keep us alive,
to stop us from touching a hot fire.
Automakers runaway from predators,
so we came up with a rights that protect
us from infringements that causes pain.
Even more abstract rights like freedom
are rooted in the way our brains are
wired to detect what is fair and unfair.
What a toaster that is unable to
move mind being locked in a cage.
Would it mind being dismantled
if it had no fear of death?
Would it mind being insulted if
it had no need for self esteem?
But what if we programmed a robot to
feel pain and emotions to prefer justice
over injustice, pleasure over
pain, and be aware of it?
Would that make them sufficiently human?
Many technologies,
it's belief that an explosion in
technology will occur when artificial
intelligence can learn
and create their own.
Artificial intelligence is even
smarter than themselves at this point.
The question of how robots are programmed
will be largely out of our control
water.
If an artificial intelligence found it
necessary to program the ability to feel
pain just as evolutionary biology found
it necessary. In most loving creatures.
Do.
Robots deserve those rights,
but maybe we should be less worried
about the risk that's superintelligent
robots post to us and more worried
about the danger we posed to them.
Our whole human identity is based
on the idea of human exceptionalism,
that we are special, unique snowflakes
in titled to dominate the natural world.
Humans have a history of denying that
other beings are capable of suffering as
they do.
In the midst of the scientific revolution,
many to cart argued that animals were
mayor. Automata robots, if you will,
as such,
injuring a rabbit was about as morally
repugnant as punching a stuffed animal
and many of the greatest
crimes against humanity.
We're justified by their perpetrators on
the grounds that the victims were more
animal than civilized human.
Even more problematic is that we have
an economic interest in denying robot
rights.
If we can coerce a sentient AI possibly
through programs torture into doing as
we please the economic
potential is unlimited.
We've done it before or after all
violence has been used to force our fellow
humans into working and we've never had
trouble coming up with an ideological
justifications.
Slave owners argued that
slavery benefited the slaves.
They put a roof over their head
and taught them. Christianity.
Men who were against women voting argued
that it was in women's own interest to
leave the hard decisions to men.
Farmers argued that looking after animals
and feeding them justifies that early
death for our dietary preferences.
If robots become sentient,
there will be no shortage of arguments
for those who say that they should remain
without rights, especially from
those who stand to profit from it.
Artificial intelligence raises serious
questions about philosophical boundaries.
While we may ask if sent in, robots
aren't conscious or deserving of rights,
it forces us to pose basic
questions like what makes us human,
what makes us deserving of rights,
regardless of what we think the question
need to be resolved in the near future.
What are we going to do with robots?
Start demanding bear own rights.
What can robots to mining
rights teach us about ourselves?
Our friends at wisecrack made a
video exploring this very question,
using the philosophy of
Westworld wisecrack dissects
pop culture and a unique
and philosophical way.
Click here to check out their video
and subscribe to their channel.